[Musica]
dunque io metto le mani avanti perché a
differenza di chi di solito parla né
that talk non sto facendo una ricerca
per cui era il cancro non sto cercando
di risolvere il problema del
riscaldamento climatico
sono abbastanza sicuro che anche
quest'anno non mi daranno un premio
nobel
io disegno disegno e anche nel mio
mestiere capitano dei fatti curiosi
tempo fa stavo lavorando alla copertina
appunto del the economist e il loro hard
director mi manda questa mail
traduco luca per favore poi fare il
titolo in maniera meno fallica e per
farvi capire questa era l'immagine
incriminata e io tutt'oggi proclamo la
mia innocenza nel senso che secondo me
la somiglianza non è così estrema lungi
da me mettere intenzionalmente un
pisello sulla copertina di un magazine
che tra l'altro è molto autorevole molto
rispettabile
da bravo professionista ho apportato le
modifiche che mi erano state richieste e
questo e poi l'immagine che è andata in
pagina
della mostra un po per farvi capire
quanto folle il mio lavoro possa essere
a volte ma soprattutto perché qui c'è
una grande lezione nonostante la mia
limpida e assoluta innocenza
nelle intenzioni in relazione erano
preoccupati che questa immagine potesse
essere letta in maniera completamente
diversa dal pubblico
questo perché per dirla con una frase di
haven air che ormai è un assioma di
tutte le discipline della comunicazione
la comunicazione non è quello che
diciamo bensì quello che arriva agli
altri se io oggi mi trovassi davanti
alla platea
di ghanesi
eschimesi o comunque persone con cui non
ho una lingua tipo di inglese in comune
con cui comunicare questo sarebbe un po
più difficile di quanto già non sia in
questo momento ho però un grande
vantaggio nel mio lavoro cioè che non
devo comunicare con degli estranei
tramite le parole ma tramite le immagini
sono abbastanza sicuro che siate tutti
guardando la mia mano in questo momento
questo non dipende dalla lingua che
parlate a prescindere dalla cultura cui
appartenete
noi siamo tutti biologicamente simili
quindi il nostro occhio e il nostro
cervello è portato a concentrarsi
istintivamente su alcune cose in
particolare una cosa che si muove su una
scena altrimenti ferma la mia mano che è
più chiara di mai vestito di scuro
questi sono meccanismi che ci hanno
portato si sono sviluppati per aiutarci
a sopravvivere in un ambiente naturale
quindi qualcosa che si muove in natura è
una preda da rincorrere un predatore da
cui scappare stessa cosa vale per i
contrasti di colore infatti noi siamo
particolarmente sensibili ai contrasti
de rossi sui verbi che non a caso sono
il colore della frutta matura su uno
sfondo di fogliame tutto questa
introduzione per dire che queste sono
reazioni
sicuramente istintive cioè non importa
da dove venite sono simili per tutti
sono reazioni che ci hanno aiutato a
sopravvivere in natura ma entrano in
campo anche quando guardiamo un'immagine
artificiale cioè un'immagine che è stata
progettata e pensata per comunicare
qualcosa in particolare
per questo motivo nel disegnare questa
immagine ho scelto un blu che contrasta
con lo sfondo giallo di modo che il
vostro sguardo sia portato a guardare la
farfalla
ovviamente ci sono molti più livelli di
lettura
noi siamo molto di più delle nostre pure
reazioni istintive e una cosa secondo me
è molto affascinante di poter lavorare
tramite con le immagini è che posso
comunicare con qualcuno che viene da una
cultura totalmente estranee alla mia ad
esempio io non parlo una singola parola
di tedesco e questa immagine è stata
pubblicata sul die zeit
settimana il settimanale tedesco si
e nonostante nonostante appunto io non
parla una parola della loro lingua in
germania milioni di persone hanno visto
e capito questa immagine anche voi
capite che parla di vaccini pur non
sapendo leggere il titolo di questo
giornale questi ponti che vengono che
vengono creati fra diverse culture
possono essere creati anche a livello
temporale
noi siamo addirittura in grado di vedere
e riconoscere
il disegno di un uomo preistorico e
direi quella è una giraffa
c'è un però nel momento in cui usciamo
dalle nostre me reazioni istintive è
necessario avere un'esperienza comune
che preceda questa esperienza
noi dobbiamo aver già visto una giraffa
per poter riconoscere una giraffa nel
disegno di un uomo preistorico questa
immagine penso sia di facilissima
lettura per tutti i presenti
se noi avessimo mostrata io l'ho
disegnato nel 2017 ma se l'avessimo
mostrata a qualcuno per la macchina del
tempo nel 1990 non avrebbe avuto senso
perché gli smartphone se non si erano
ancora diffusi ovviamente non siano
ancora diffuse le app di incontri e allo
stesso modo questa copertina che ho
disegnato per il diacono miss ha senso
per noi che abbiamo avuto la sfortuna di
vivere la pandemia e quindi ci
ricordiamo tutti il momento che speriamo
adesso non torni in cui l'unico modo per
uscire di casa era portare a spasso il
cane mostrare questa questa immagine a
qualcuno venti anni fa non avrebbe avuto
significato
le immagini hanno inoltre un potere
molto più immediato e conciso rispetto
alla parola scritta vi propongo un altro
piccolo esperimento
provate a pensare che io sia un politico
e che faccio un discorso al popolo con
alle spalle questa slide i caratteri
sono abbastanza piccoli ci mettereste un
po anche solo capire in che lingua
redatto sono qua davanti da dieci
secondi e non vi siete resi conto che
una pagina del mein kampf provate a
pensare un politico che parla di davanti
a questa slide l'effetto è un attimo il
più disturbante
però attenzione è un effetto che è data
da delle convenzioni che dipendono dalla
nostra cultura nella cultura asiatica
nella cultura indiana la svastica è
associata a dei significati
completamente diversi come la pace
l'armonia il dio sole e quindi c'è
questa differenza il linguaggio visivo
funziona con dei meccanismi spesso molto
simili a quello verbale cioè noi abbiamo
da una parte un significato la giraffa e
dall'altra parte del significante che
noi come convenzione leghiamo a quel
significato come appunto la parola
giraffa questo vuol dire guarda al mare
in finlandese per farvi capire
direttamente quindi un suono c'è un
significante che per noi non si ha un
significato totalmente diverso cazzo
merda vuol dire guarda al mare in
finlandese
allo stesso modo un segno che può essere
il crisantemo in giappone è associato a
significati di immortalità sapete
benissimo che danno il crisantemo è il
fiore dei morti
allo stesso modo se per stare in tema se
fossimo così sfortunati da dover andare
a un funerale in giappone e ci andassimo
vestiti di nero saremmo gli unici perché
il colore il colore funebre associato al
lutto in giappone non è nero bensì il
bianco e quindi appunto ci sono queste
differenze fra quelli che sono i
significati e significanti
addirittura in alcune culture c'è un
rapporto totalmente diverso con il mondo
delle immagini
basti pensare che nell'impero ottomano
nel cinquecento diceva allah ni con ismo
e quindi era fatto divieto esplicito di
rappresentare gli esseri viventi questo
è solimano il magnifico sultano di
costantinopoli non proprio l'ultima
ruota del carro ed era costretto a
rivolgersi a questo è un dipinto di
tiziano comunque i pittori veneziani per
farsi ritrarre perché in patria
questo non era concesso
guardate adesso questa illustrazione e
novio richiamo ai fatti di piazza
tienanmen e rassegnata tra gennaio e
febbraio 2020 vi ricordate tutti cosa
stava succedendo al virus aveva appena
cominciato a circolare in cina non era
ancora diventata una pandemia
e i giornali europei questo è per
l'express in francia si domandavano come
una cosa così minuscola come appunto il
coronavirus fosse stata il granello di
sabbia nell'ingranaggio che ha fermato
l'avanzata del gigante cinese
bene quello che per noi è un'immagine
relativamente innocua in cina ricevuta
in maniera totalmente diversa
dopo aver lavorato sui social media mi
sono arrivate valanghe di insulti perché
per loro è un tasto molto dolente la
foto di piazza di tiananmen da cui è è
presa questa immagine
telefonata alle 3 del mattino insulti
alla mamma insomma cioè cosa avevate la
gente si offende e il fatto che ognuno
di noi ha una propria cultura visiva
personale non sto più parlando di
cultura occidentale e cultura orientale
o cultura italiana cultura messicana a
quello che volete facendo che ognuno di
noi ha un suo personale bagaglio di
esperienze visive e di immagine che
associa a determinate significati
nel momento in cui noi vogliamo
comunicare con un pubblico ampio ed
eterogeneo perché ognuno al suo mondo
allora dobbiamo pescare dentro a un
immaginario visivo che deve essere il
più condiviso possibile
quasi tutti noi conosciamo
l'associazione fra don chisciotte e
mulini a vento vuol dire che tutti al
mondo la conoscono ovviamente no siamo
stati co questa illustrazione a qualcuno
a un indigeno della foresta amazzonica e
conoscerebbe forse il cavallo come noi
abbiamo riconosciuto da giraffa prima ma
ovviamente si perderebbe senso narrativo
di tutto ad illustrazione
ci sono poi dei modi per comunicare
in maniera inequivocabile con le
immagini ad esempio il disegno tecnico
se ho bisogno di far produrre una
valvola a taiwan non li mando di scure
una descrizione scritta mi mandò questo
disegno che è inequivocabile la valvola
così va costruita il problema è che c'è
un linguaggio e delle convenzioni
standardizzate iper specialistiche e noi
vogliamo parlare a un pubblico ampio
milioni di persone non solo agli
ingegneri con buona pace degli ingegneri
il fatto che appena usciamo da quelli
che sono gli standard e la sicurezza
delle convenzioni di un disegno tecnico
l'incomprensione è subito dietro l'altro
per dirla con le parole del filosofo
popper è impossibile parlare in modo
tale da non essere frainteso
in questa frase il termine parlare può
essere facilmente sostituito dal termine
comunicare e quindi si applica anche
alla comunicazione visiva è pieno il
mondo di immagini ambigue quindi
immagini che noi possiamo vedere in un
modo o in un altro questa viene mostrata
in tutti i corsi di design ormai da fine
ottocento quando è stata disegnata e il
nostro cervello deve decidere se sta
vedendo la testa di un'anatra ho la
testa di un coniglio e quindi c'è questa
ambiguità insita nelle immagini
quando come me per lavoro dovete
comunicare un concetto preciso
utilizzando un'immagine capite che
questo è un bel problema
lo è infatti ci sono un sacco di
situazioni come quella delle immagini
piazzati noaman il dito che sembra un
pisello ma allo stesso tempo è proprio
questo che da un potere evocativo e
comunicativo e anche narrativo a
un'immagine se voi guardate questa mia
illustrazione la vostra mente deve
decidere un contesto sto guardando della
frutta o sto guardando dei segnali di
divieto sono due elementi in apparenza
slegati ma la vostra mente è
costruita per cercare un ordine nel caos
e quindi se questi due elementi sono
presenti in pagina deve esserci una
relazione e se non c'è è la vostra mente
che la crea e quindi che va a capire che
questa illustrazione amministrazione che
parla di proibizionismo
in tema dei codici naturalmente spesso
mi viene chiesto
da dove vengano le mie idee è in realtà
un processo estremamente semplice in due
fasi prima fase disperazione totale
lascio il mio lavoro perché non ho
trovato un lavoro in banca sicuro e la
fase successiva consiste nel cercare
dentro quella che è la mia memoria la
mia cultura visiva degli elementi che
possano andare a rappresentare
determinati parti di un articolo che sto
cercando di illustrare se poi sono
fortunate riesca a trovare qualcosa come
il sacchetto di dare al coniglio che
esce dal cilindro che fanno anche un
click
a livello grafico
ma questa è solo la mia parte del lavoro
perché a completare il processo siete
voi siete voi che unite i puntini è
sostanzialmente l'incontro ricordiamoci
quello che abbiamo detto all'inizio
comunicare non è quello che diciamo ma è
quello che arriva agli altri con questo
non voglio dire che voi siete spettatori
passivi e un'immagine il fuoco si può
colpire nella maniera hicks o nella
maniera y se proprio dicendo che siete
voi i protagonisti di questo processo
siete voi che mettete insieme gli
elementi perché io mi limito a metterli
in quel rettangolo
ma la magia non avviene in quel
rettangolo avviene dentro di voi
sostanzialmente è l'incontro fra quella
che è la mia cultura visiva e la vostra
che crea il significato che arriva al
vostro cervello
sta di fatto che
se dovessero atterrare gli alieni
dopodomani e dovesse comunicarci in
qualche modo forse chiameranno nello
stato re grazie
[Applauso]